welcome to run number functions in C
qualité what the f
blue torii important legal information
that's boring okay so it's a little bit
about me software engineering J Sigma
I've done a lot of open source Python
tools mostly in the PI data a data
analysis space and I like interesting
hacks so I don't know if you'd call this
talk interesting but hopefully it will
be ok so just fair warning
like hacks ahead many hacks you probably
should not use this software but maybe
it'll maybe you'll you'll learn
something and find something interesting
the main takeaway here is that numbers
probably more powerful than you think it
is and it's not that hard to extend you
know if you put in a lot of hours so
what do I mean by hard well so the first
thing we need to talk about is what it
what it looks like to actually like
stick something into sequel light so
what does it look like to extend it just
a couple of terms we're gonna be working
with here this is it for the sort of
jargon is UDF user defined function au
DAF which is a user defined aggregate
function we're mostly gonna be focusing
on the second one aggregate functions
because the sort of vanilla UDF's aren't
that interesting so what does it look
like to actually do some of these things
like write a UDF or a UDA F inside of
Python you can just import sequel i3
which is in the standard library you
fire up a connection here I'm making
in-memory connection to find some Python
function called con you know connect a
connection or a function give it the
name the number bargain
and the Python function object and then
you can start calling it inside of the
database how many people knew this
existed interesting you can only work
with like the inputs and the outputs can
only be sort of like very simple types
right you can't return like a lip list
of dicks of strings to other lists of
Lintz right you can't do really do that
you can you can take strings return
strings bytes integers floats that's
about it
so UDF's are a little bit more
interesting you define a class which
implements these two methods step and
finalize I made it go over exactly how
that works and what it looks like and
you also have to define a constructor
that takes no arguments which
initializes like variables that you're
going to use during the aggregation so
the actual flow of like you know how
this class is used so first single ID is
gonna initialize scratch base to hold
intermediate values and this is these
are like the values so going back here
this is a values of like total and count
right so you actually need to
instantiate the class is basically
what's happening there like for each row
in the column that you call your
function on it's gonna call step with
this scratch space and the arguments
that you give it finally after all rows
have been traversed I was gonna call
finalize which gives you a chance to
like tidy up and finish up your
computation so what so let's kind of be
a little more concrete here let's say I
have this table called tea it's got two
columns K and V and I want to take the
average of that with my with my UDF so
what does that look like and to be clear
this is actually how sequel Lite itself
does all of its internal aggregations
they're just defined using C which we're
gonna get into later so as we start with
Tolan counts at the zero
we then call step on the first row of V
okay we then so what that did was it
added one two total and one to count and
then we go to the next row we add two to
our value of one which gives a three and
we add 1 to the count those are sort of
interesting we basically just ignore
them like we just don't update any of
our values if we see a null this is up
to the user of course like you can do
whatever you want I mean you can drop
your database if you had an OL or
something don't do that but you could so
nothing happens there then we add 4 2 3
gives us 7 we had 1 to the con then we
add 5 to 7 she was 12 and we add 1 to
the count again so now we've traversed
all rows the next step is to go finalize
which since we're computing an average
we take we divide total by count then we
get the average what does that look like
to use it
others you just it looks similar to
create function or whatever it was
called you give it the name of the
function that as you would call it in in
sequel the number of arguments the step
method takes and the class how many
people knew this existed I can't imagine
the other yeah anyway so this is what it
would look like to use it this with T
thing is called a common table
expression I'm just doing something
really boring and showing that you can
actually call this this function that is
calling into this class get the average
so the C story is like a little bit
different there are a lot of
similarities there just a lot there's a
lot more boilerplate you got to do a lot
more you got to be a lot more careful
about allocation and things like that so
this is a little little weird right
this is what a step function a
user-defined step function would look
like in sequel a and I'm gonna walk you
through it so it's actually not that
scary and you'll kind of see that
there's exactly one piece of code we
actually care about
so the scratch piece has to be defined
you usually you define a compile time in
this case I'm making a struct who's like
values are you know the same as my
Python class I just have to say what the
type is for the first thing I'm going to
do is compute the size of this struct
like the compile time size so it's gonna
be 8 byte sorry 16 bytes there's gonna
be a double which is 8 bytes and an n64
which is 8 bytes I'm then gonna make
this call into this this is the sequel
light capi sequel I 3 I recon text and
what that does is it says allocate some
memory allocated zactly n bytes and the
interesting thing is that went on the
second call to step it's going to give
you the same memory you allocated on the
first call which allows you to keep
updating that state it gives you back a
raw pointer a void pointer which
basically has no like utility at all
except to be cast to something else
so here what we do is we cast that to
our struct this is a check to make sure
that we actually were able to allocate
memory there's no else branch here so
they're like there's no error handling
in this version of the code because you
know why hair fly handle errors when you
don't have to so the next step is we're
gonna get out the first argument which
is the argument to the function that the
user provided we're gonna get the type
out which is sort of like a
and see if it's not null basically if
the value isn't null pull out the value
as a double and then do the thing that
we actually want to do like this is the
core logic to our aggregation there's an
interesting thing about sequel why is
that it's dynamically typed similar to
pythons or like in Python and C Python
there's an object called PI object which
every value in Python is an instance of
and in similarly in sequel light like if
you have a string if you have an integer
of a floating-point value it's like seek
like value star this is very similar to
PI object but this is the core thing
that we want to extract and we want to
like I want to make this simpler I want
it to run at C speed and I also don't
want have to write all this joke
finalize is similar it's you still have
to like pull the a great context out
cast it check for the null pointer check
to see if like the number of non null
values is greater than zero at Sarat
Serra
but you only land on this singular piece
of logic that you care about so when I
started working on this I had basically
no goals except to just like make my
head explode but there's sort of a goal
here which is we want the Python
standard library API but we want C
speeds
this is a quick C refresher function
pointers are pointers pointers are
integers function pointers are therefore
integers not all integers are function
pointers but some are
maybe some people know where I'm going
with this but basically like you you
really don't want to be dealing with
like function pointers is integers
generically like generally speaking
they're sort of dangerous so don't ever
call a function pointer that somebody
has handed you as an integer something
like this is like really like don't do
this I don't make a form that accepts an
integer and just like casts it to a
function point hearing you will be very
sad okay
so numb who hears use number okay cool
has anybody extended number with like
intrinsic okay that fine those people
who raised their hands we'll get into
that in a bit so if you haven't used
number numbers this very interesting
project originally started at anaconda
when it was continuum analytics and is
now still being developed inside of
anaconda what it allows you to do is
write very fast numeric code in Python
and it uses a technology called LLVM
which will compile Python byte code to
machine code as Python is running it's a
very interesting piece of technology
it's extremely useful if you want to
like you know if you have some
computation that's difficult to express
in a vectorized manner number can really
help you out it also has some neat
features like JIT classes which are
relatively new they let you define
classes that number will compile to
machine code as Python is running it's
extensible the dev team is extremely
helpful there's a mailing lists on
Google Groups and they're you know one
of the things I went on there tasks for
one of the things that I needed for this
and how to sort of deal with the issue
that I wanted to deal with them
so they're very helpful there's also
this thing called C funk which is
basically the underpin like underlies
all of the insanity we're about to get
into but first let's talk about J
classes this is the average class from
before right it's called I didn't use
total its value but so that's basically
all you have to do to like turn your to
like justify your class like the first
time I saw this I was like like this is
this is insane
this is there's like like what okay so
more or less this is kind of like if
you've done any C programming this is
kind of what that looks like
numbah will create two functions that
take the this struct average as the
first argument and then whatever other
arguments you have in there it will make
function well the function will take
those as well I'm like totally glossing
over a lot of details here there's a lot
more stuff that goes on but this like
conceptually is like what it does so
let's get to a more specific goal we
want to call jetted method from a c
function that we define in Python that
matches the sequel it--see API this is
this is like what the heck is going on
here I mean so what C func do
see funk has sort of in the same lines
is just like taking an image like an
injure and like casting it to a function
player hoping for the best
it's a number decorator you slap it on
to a function you have to give it a
signature it doesn't it's not gonna
magically like figure out four people
have used number before it's not imagine
we figure out what the inputs are and
that's because it actually needs to like
give you something back that can be
immediately called in C and C isn't very
happy if you don't tell it what the
types of the thing that you're computing
on are you can also do this which is
dangerous but it turns out that this is
a critical for exposing number JIT
classes and functions inside of sequa
light so i created something called
slumber number like gives you the LLVM
code gen user provides Stephane
finalized methods that what's left
this isn't similar important legal
information it's important renaming
information some of my co-workers
suggested that I change the num the name
from slumber to n um SQL which is
pronounced numbskull you might be asking
yourself this question shortly so
numbskull kind of ties everything
together and this is these I'm gonna go
through kind of defining like how you
would use this stuff using numbskull so
you import another decorator you give it
a signature you take your number JIT
class and then you write the same thing
that you wrote before
but the first thing you do it's lumba
then defines rappers four-step and
finalized which looks strikingly similar
to the c code
the main difference here is that like
mmm like 80% of the code here is like
their custom things that I had to write
because they don't exist in number and
they're also like pretty dangerous and
they're also not anything that is like
sort of generically useful maybe with
the exception of not null so what we're
gonna focus on step though because that
that really has like the more
interesting piece of code here so it's
kind of walk through what that's doing
again just like from the Python side of
things so again like this is kind of
unchanged like sizeof doesn't really
exist in number that was that was like
probably the easiest thing to implement
but you give it you know a context it
gives you back a raw pointer somehow
that magically exists since I have
Python then we cast that pointer to our
JIT class type
if we successfully allocated memory like
call our method so make our tuple is
it's like a total Odyssey of weird like
LVM hacks and we're just gonna like dive
right into that so what problem does
make are to pull solve look first of all
it's totally insane that you can are
like splat in a couple into like
something that's eventually gonna be
like called from C so the thing we're
solving is actually this sort of like
type inference problem in in kind of
like a we're basically saying yeah we're
not gonna solve that so the problem is
that that secretly sequel I value
doesn't have a type until runtime right
so like in this case what I'm doing is
building it an argument tuple and I'm
saying for each argument
give me the type if it's a if it's a
sequel I'd float like append it to the
tupple of Zener appended and that's a
supple but I'm first like extracting the
those values as they're C values right
but remember when we actually like made
people define this class they have to
give us the signature so we don't
actually need to do that type checking
at runtime we can just generate an
argument tupple using LLVM before right
before you run this function in sin with
machine code we require argument types
so it's not actually necessary to do
that and that this is like most of what
make our topple looks like except that
there's like some totally insane magic
in here and we're gonna I'm going to
show you like a sort of what that looks
like I fixed a bug earlier where it
wasn't handling nulls and like that made
it significantly more complicated so
this is like this was why I did this it
was like melting my face a little bit so
this is the core of what make our tuple
looks like and and what it's doing is
it's saying okay
I have this argument type which is what
the user passed in so in our case it's a
float64 there's a you're getting out of
C types function you're then telling
numba to make that into some kind of
number function that you can then call
you get an LLVM instruction out FN for
the eyuth argument you get out a pointer
to that you D ref that pointer and then
you call our function on this element
guess I that would have been more useful
after that sandy number happily jits
that this is like a you know impossible
triangle with all these technologies so
I'm not working together then you
register your AG with the DB and you can
start calling it insider sequel I
so what slump will provide size of
unsafe cast check the pointers not null
in this weird thing so that's pretty
much it I have some other things but
we're running low on time so if anyone
you know okay I don't if I have anything
super useful oh yeah so I do I do have a
a some vaporware and some really
disappointing benchmarks which basically
like like whole table aggregation is
like much faster I guess the good news
is or is we're not any slower than the
built-ins equal life functions so this
is a sensing average and if you take a
whole table I think I don't remember
this index or not but you take a whole
table you aggregate it it's about five
times faster to to use number it's like
one and a half you know for a high
cardinality group by like if you know
the number like the percentage of unique
values in the column your your grouping
on is high you don't get that much
benefit and it's about 2x faster for a
low cardinality group I think like it's
a 1% unique values in the low
cardinality case in 90% in the high
there's like basically no reason to talk
about scalar functions for performance
they're kind of neck-and-neck with
Python
what Samba doesn't do is anything that
involves the heap so if something that
takes basically operates row-wise on a
column so like if you want to add one or
something like that
yeah like anchor
yeah I think the dynamic typing combined
with like allocation and nioh is gonna
like dominate for like your actual
computation so someone doesn't handle
anything I'm going to do with the heap
like if you want to do that you
basically have to take a void pointer in
and like you know start calling in to
see types or some other totally insane
thing that you probably shouldn't do you
probably would also have to extend
number itself to make this work like
beyond making your own intrinsics lots
of stuff looks like that so this may or
may not be a blocker for anything
I had a demo which I can show very
quickly so it's bigger
import our thing basically declare that
you know our class so this is actually
the sequel I recently added support for
window functions so I added support for
that in in slumber so we define our
class we connect to our database we
create our aggregate oh that's the other
thing I've used a special create
aggregate function otherwise you can't
get access to the actual important
object inside of the sequel Lite because
Python doesn't expose that and it's the
API which is totally in normal because
it's a pointer so and then we'll just
we'll call it so it's comparing against
the built in average there so that works
I don't know vast that this works I
don't know if I'd say works for this
library but it does everything I've told
you it does in this talk and and that's
pretty much it
we have time for questions okay cool
well help me yeah anyone has questions
so what got you to ask this question in
the first place like how did like what
was the winding road that got you to
number functions in sequel like so I
originally wanted to do this for
Postgres which it turns out is
significantly more complicated both from
an actual just software point of view
and the way in which user-defined
functions are defined they're also a lot
more powerful they have a lot more
options about what kind of types you can
take in and and produce but the the sort
of main limitation there which I haven't
thought too hard about is that
user-defined functions in C or compiled
code are coming from a shared library
that is on disk
whereas all this stuff is happening in
memory and sequel I'd takes a function
pointer which lives in memory and so
that that was like way easier so I was
like let me get this into a database and
then I saw C funk come along and I was
like there it is
cool
nice thank you
[Applause]